what a fascinating character for you to
be able to just kind of like dig into
now obviously you're building a
character to tell the story which
doesn't necessarily mean impersonation
but was there
a particular trait of anna's that you
for yourself just had to get right for
this performance
um
well
just really the thing that i had to get
right was the accent you know the accent
to me
gave a lot away as you know this the
accent is
an accent of a person that is trying to
be something that she's not and that's
really what anna is
um so that was the first important step
um
but those little traits those
characteristics i mean
no
i there's certain things that i pay
attention to that i just add in there to
make the character more human but that's
for any job that i that i do
what for you was
the most intriguing part of this story
because there's so many aspects to her
character characters she may have played
and the way that she operated that i
think people find so intriguing
you know i think people find
anna intriguing for multiple reasons
whether you love it or you hate it um
i think people have
uh people are
intrigued always by things that they
love and they hate you know always
things that are interesting or are
things that are contradicting itself um
but uh
yeah so to me i think that's why people
gravitate towards it but i also think
people gravitate towards it because i
really think the stories about identity
and
the people struggling with their
identity and
um
how
people in this especially in this day
and age are not having an okay time
being themselves but pretending like
they're okay being themselves
because that's what they you know put on
social media um in a way so yeah
the idea of like fake it till you make
it is
like a culture
right like it's what people just do
do you ever recall being in a situation
where you were like
i'm kind of faking it and it's working
and you get the thrill that i imagine
you know anna must have felt or maybe
maybe she didn't feel it but it seems
like you know what i mean like i i fake
it till i make it i feel like every i
mean i'm i my job is to recite other
people's words that aren't my words so i
literally
think that these are this is the first
time i'm saying certain lines when i
said it in my room you know a thousand
times
like and i'm saying it like it's the
first time but but i don't think anna
ever really thought fake it till she
makes it i think if she more thought
you know playing her and experiencing
how she was thinking
i think
if a person doesn't have belief within
themselves then it's very hard for
people to have belief around you and to
believe in you in a way if you don't
have that inner belief so i think anna
believed in herself but i don't know if
she went about it in the right way
how interested are you
in
knowing how she feels about your
portrayal of her and her story
you know i i mean of course it's
you know there's a degree that i'm
interested but at the same time if you
know i i never uh when i started this
project i never had any expectation
that you know she
was gonna watch it or not gonna watch it
you know i kind of just wanted to tell
her story in a way um and i'm still kind
of sticking to that mentality
you know you you're saying that she
didn't think of it maybe as as fake it
so you make it do you think that she uh
do you think she feels anything for you
know the people that she got money from
yeah i do
even if if
you know it's hard for her to admit it
right on well thank you so much complex
you know it's very and you know what the
show really explores that very very well
you did a fantastic job thank you for
the time thank you so much thank you
you